I will be showing you a game that I
found in girlfriend's positional
decision-making book I think it's a very
good idea to show this game in order to
explain to you how you should play when
you have space event so let's first run
through the opening
okay nothing very interesting has
happened so far but I would say that
white has played a slightly better
opening in is a little bit better
because of that now in the context of
you know the structures that I discuss
in my book this is what you might call a
king's indian complex we have the six
points in the typical squares c4 d 4 f 4
vs c 6 d 6 and 5 and plenty of things
could happen now like for example we
could trade only 5 that would be one
type of position we could wait for our
opponent to take or we could push and
then once we push there is another
question which is what will our opponent
do
should our opponent trade on d5 or play
C 5 and those different decisions give
rise to very different positions so let
me just give you a brief idea about that
so first let's suppose that black played
c5 how do you think white should play
now
what should be the main plan go ahead
Eddie
a3 if they take sure sure okay so you
want to play a three and then before I
like that that's a very good idea now I
want to ask you yeah yeah okay so then
broadly speaking there are two main
ideas to do here you can either break
with before or you can break with f4
they can both be good in certain
positions but in this position I
definitely think that a 3 and B 4 is a
better idea okay we can later discuss in
which positions at the f4 break is more
effective is not very effective in this
position so first of all if we play 92
automatically those bishops are going to
be out of the board right and then after
that you're thinking about doing what
now I want to show you something look at
this night on T 2 where is it going to
go what do you think what use can you
get out of this night yeah it's not a
good square I mean think about it I mean
how impressive is this night right here
I mean it's like if you have this
position I mean do you really like that
right
I don't I I don't see what's the point
of it
but maybe but that's not very likely cuz
it opponent will stop it with d6 it will
be a lot of moves to then be stopped but
you know a much more reasonable thing to
try in this position will be to play 91
y 91 because okay we are gonna trade
those bishops oh and let me ask another
question am I happy to trade those
bishops yes or no yes why exactly
exactly so the pawns are light square so
when you trade that Bishop you have a
positional advantage with white where
you have got rid of your opponent's good
bishop
you have got rid of your bad bishop and
then the rest of the game will be a
little bit easier for you because of
that so the trade is desirable but
because the knight on the two didn't
have much I put the night only one and
what am I thinking about I'm thinking
about maybe playing Knight e3 and then
similar ideas right but then I will keep
the knight on the three is much more
helpful there and then maybe I'll end up
playing something like this and then
I'll play a four and then a five that
makes way more sense which brings us
back to a general rule which I would say
is the following if you have a Kings
Indian type 2 which is this position
with this six points where they are then
the pawn is going to be stuck on c4
forever which means that the night only
two doesn't have anywhere to go so in
this position you play 91 that's the
right thing to do did you understand
that c5 and 91 now if your opponent took
on the other hand now c4 is available so
what you do instead
for example it'll open a plate there is
92 and now then I can go to D equal to
c4 and that's pretty good now let's look
at this position for a moment who would
you rather be white or black
okay and then maybe I'm bringing an eye
to see for so if black plays b5 what
would you do with white a for looks
pretty good even better
Brooke see one and then I fold so when
you push me away I can go to dig one but
my truck is already coming up so if you
move the pawn rook c6 how do you feel
about this so this is great now it is
typical for white to have an advantage
on the Queen side well Black's attacking
on the Kings side the problem is that
here black doesn't have anything on the
Kings side right they attack on the
cancer is completely delayed so here
white is doing great so this position is
essentially unacceptable for black so
anyway after d5 they came continued upon
take one take and before I get to do
this 92 black took in my book this would
be cold think a Kings Indian type one
and it would generally be a good
position for white but now let's try to
understand this game because it is very
interesting what happens here so here
black played queen p8 can any of you
tell me what is the plan that black is
aiming for
no I mean that that's a decent idea it
is everyone's first guess be five before
not the main plan like as something much
more powerful who has a space advantage
it's a pretty substantial space
advantage right the pawn on d5 kind of
annoying so people typically say
something about space advantage what do
they say trade pieces what kinds of
pieces rooks queens will work whatever
pieces no no no actually what you should
do in a position like this is you trade
minor pieces that's the best advice I
can give you used focus on trading minor
pieces so if you are black what's your
goal you want to trade your knights and
the bishop so what's the idea of playing
Queen b8 exactly exactly so if I do not
sing you'll play there and then what can
you tell me about these two bishops
which one is better which one is worse
yeah
right and then what we have been saying
is that in this stable position if you
have traded that Bishop then any hope
for an advantage is kind of evaporates
right so if you're white you definitely
don't want to allow that okay so you're
white
your opponent just played Queen b8 what
will you do with white what's the nicest
way you can use to prevent that trade
and please don't say I'm gonna remove
the bishop because the diagonal is
important
a4 a5 good so you play a four you might
think that we played a four tuple then
b5 but no no that's not the reason we
played a four in order to prevent Bishop
b6 right so if your opponent played this
you play a five preventing bishop basis
now what is your opponent plays a5 try
to play this again yeah how about you
play Queen b3 so now this is impossible
again right okay so it seems like you
know black can't just force that move so
in the game black just played rook c8 a
five fish of the okay so there is a hope
that someday they will be able to do it
okay now I played Bishop e2 and black
played b5 so let me ask you will you
take that one with a knight with the
bishop or with the pawn what do you
think
right so let's go through the
possibilities if I take the pawn you
will take only forth who favors from
that trade why excellent yes what do you
want to say very good thinking okay so
overall that's a disaster move for white
white we should never even consider this
what if you take with the Bishop rook
now the bishop is hanging you take on
the seven now I take on e3 Black has an
advantage here right we got two pieces
for the route this is not acceptable
again so going back a little bit why it
cannot take what do you take with the
pawn let's say you take with the pawn
and then your opponent just take some b6
what is that it's trading is this is
exactly what we were trying to avoid so
no not acceptable so let's go back a
little bit after b5 white is paid of
three consolidating the pawn on e4
making sure that before does not work if
your opponent played before anyway well
where would you put this night yeah
but the pawn on e5 would be hanging
well we'll be careful
No so 94 not good 95 not good so only
move with then a 91 and then you can pay
92 and 94 and that's pretty good for a
white don't don't you think so then
black doesn't want to weaken that square
so he just played a six now let's say I
give you this position with white so the
question here is how can you create a
plan in order to create a plan the first
thing you need to realize is where
what's the source of your advantage if
you have one so okay okay be more
specific we have space advantage that's
the source of the advantage we have
right it's not much but we have some
space advantage we want to profit from
that now can we put a knight on c6 for
example would that be a worthwhile goal
okay let's go through that
okay so let's say you play g3 okay I'm
gonna play Queen d7 you play a four I
take take and I play before then the
pawn is hanging right now let's say you
want to try something else like you want
to support the pond first okay fine I'm
gonna play rooks I'm gonna play maybe
here just to do something in the
meantime you play a four I take take now
I play here I'm gonna trade the bishop
king ash won a play Bishop i7d - okay
now I play Knight see yeah exactly so
you didn't trade but it's not a good so
it's not this is not a great position
for white ok trade it
okay maybe I should have played this
well I mean no I mean this could be okay
all I'm saying is I don't think is that
advantageous the producers position
there's a word for it it's called one
sided the previous position was one
sided Whitehead threats black didn't
hear we can both create threats right
that's the problem that I see with this
overall idea instead okay there's one
element that you haven't considered yet
is the open file there is an open file
we should maybe try to use it so here we
just played rook f2 and then black try
to go all the way to trade this bishop
okay fine
now I play now that you have removed
your bishop from this diagonal I can put
the night to before right without having
to lose this fi pawn I'm going to c6 now
we have traded one minor piece so we are
not so happy about that right we lost a
little bit of us our space advantage
another it's an open file and then the
question is should we fight for it or
not because in the process of fighting
for it we will end up trading all the
roofs so what do you think okay but so
the question is here's the big question
are you willing to trade the rooks yes
or no right and then do you think there
is any meaning in having these rooks
outside of the open file there is no use
for them right so we have to fight for
the open file panel let me ask you this
is the question are we losing the space
advantage when we do this why not
okay and some other reason that I said
earlier space advantage is pay is based
on the amount of minor pieces in the
board not major pieces minor pieces
meaning knights and bishops rooks and
queens are very good at creating some
sort of counter play sort of like
infiltrating your opponent's position
when he expands a little bit too much so
eliminating the rooks does not eliminate
our space advantage but it does help us
to minimize counter play so we have
traded everything and now here let's
take a guess can we win this yes or no
how okay
something like that okay so here the
game continued 97 king f2 King III and
now before yeah not sure what has an
advantage there is some substantial
specs advantage because I have the pawn
on f5 and I have the pawn on d5 now let
me ask you if you were black why will
you go back or go forward
go back okay so let me ask you what's
wrong with playing night a for ya
yeah is it reversible right it's like a
very communal decision now the reason
that I play this is that if I go back I
have very little space so my nights kind
of conflict with each other but if I go
forward then at least the nights have a
little bit more freedom yeah that's
another problem so let me ask you if you
were white here wait wait wait
if you were white here how would you
play and it seems like nobody likes this
night a for idea so I want to see how
are you trying to beat me show me
Kingda - okay
mate okay keep going okay mm-hmm
do you realize that you cannot take
because of this right you're losing this
point okay so you said King b3 right
okay now I play Knight f6 okay and then
again you cannot take because this phone
is always hanging right I'm gonna play
g5 now the best what you do
maybe now I am not really but you can
see that white is not exactly winning
here right but we were hoping to win
come on okay so what's the evaluation of
this position crazy
okay very accurate okay good so you
agree with me this is not a very
clear-cut advantage yeah I know but
let's look at how you could have played
so this is the way to play Mishra's free
preventing at five
okay so that's one thing
next you maneuver a little bit right now
no no play Bishop f1 Bishop one is a
nice move what's the threat yes
Knight takes d5 trapped in the night
okay so you have finally managed to find
out find a way to take advantage of the
night night a seven okay now for now
that you're sort of tied to the Queen
set I can sort of make this annoying
move F fallen try to put some pressure
if you take on a four then I will just
take and then I will push only five
Sunday and then I have then d4 for the
night
so here the line is f6 okay so now we go
around now we play Bishop h3 we should
be six
we are gaining even more space of course
if we are going to play a five I'm first
gonna put the bishop inside right so now
the question is how will you continue
you have a pretty good advantage
how will you convert this into a win I
mean that looks pretty but so you play
this right and then this and then what
if I do nothing
what's your threat
okay that's all you don't need to go to
see Fort do you agree with me yeah okay
so this line is actually 91 93 okay okay
and then G for how does white come up
with this it was very easy this is a
pond chain right so we attack the base
of the chain what is the base of the
chain Felix what is the basis of the
chain no who taught you this
yeah I mean when you have a pawn chain
no no no wait a minute wait a minute
when we talk about a pawn chain you have
you have to think about blocked pawns
you have to think about no no no no but
let's discuss it in this way where is
the pawn chain exactly the polishing we
are talking about the ponds that are
blocked so these six points are blocked
so the base of the points in here I'm
talking about f 6 D 6 2 but here we are
paying attention to this one so we're
playing g5 why do we play g5 because we
want to attack the base of the chain
right now if you're white you have two
decisions to make one you can take on f6
and focus on attacking the base of the
chain or you can push g6 and then now
the new base of the chain is g7 right
because it's the most backward blocked
pawn and then you can try to attack
adjustor so the question for you is what
do you choose to do
right so you're saying take take nourish
- and you're gonna win the pawn right
away that's good what about you play g6
what do you think black can do here you
will very quickly realize that black
does not have a lot of moves he can
basically move the King right
you can see how to win right well let me
show you let's say you move the king
okay obviously what am I going to bring
this night okay no no but the final
square h5 so we're all going there okay
we can all agree on that so okay it
doesn't matter how we get there but it's
happy there oh yeah okay we made it now
what can black play
he has one acceptable move 98 and then
after Bishop CIT can resign right but
we're gonna take it I mean I'm gonna
take this pawn right and then this
pointer hand in the night yeah both
moons are winning I personally like the
sixth better because I got a sucks on
but I think they are both winning now
going back it seems that this position
is just not something that black and
safe so after before black had to play
just 97
now obviously f5 could be annoying right
so I will prevent it by playing Bishop
III what will you do now
a four very good so you play a fourth
and what now your opponent is kind of
under pressure only five and then the
problem here is that well there is not a
lot you can do other than to defend if
you take I mean that's kind of scary now
because if you take I will take and then
someday I will let up playing this e5
right but the problem is I'm I'm not in
a rush right like I can do it whenever I
want and I can do a lot of annoying
things in the meantime you don't have a
lot of options so this is really not a
nice situation to be on maybe I would
play like that and then there is in this
and I have a pretty strong feeling that
one way or another you are going to lose
this which one
oh you mean trade everything here maybe
maybe yes but anyway black we just play
the six
so then how will you make progress now
f5 oh my god no be careful with this
moves this moves are very committed okay
you have an advantage but this move is
very communal it's like you're blocking
everything and you're blocking
everything with your [ __ ] about side
maybe you play we should be six and then
if I mean maybe that's worth considering
a little bit more but before you even do
that how about I mean howhow is the King
gonna come inside right if you start
just pushing him you will block
everything it will end up being a draw
you have to be careful with that
so then how about you play Bishop c8 and
then start bringing the king bless you
then you're about to play g6 I don't
like you it's fine okay we are pretty
blocked now let's identify weaknesses
for a moment which weaknesses does black
have
g7 a six and this is three weaknesses so
how do we take advantage of them okay we
we keep this Bishop in this diagonal so
that maybe someday we can take on a six
what else what about the night where
should the night be
there okay something more realistic if
6g 686 they don't attack very much f5 f5
look look at that f5 annoying for both
right okay so the game has a natural
continuation which is negative - okay
boom
okay here we're going now the problem is
when you get to a5 you don't have a
threat so sad right I mean I just pay 97
you don't have any way to make progress
so then that's kind of did ah so this is
kind of the puzzle for you you have this
position we have played a great game
right we managed to well what did we do
exactly we took some of some space
advantage in the center at the beginning
of the game then we managed to maintain
the advantage maintain a clear position
then push more pawns gain more space I
mean you you will notice the pawn on f5
and the pond on h5 both give us more
space advantage right we have a better
King everything is a slightly better but
our opponents very strong this is not
giving us the game so then the question
is how do you convert this into an
actual win so Bishop g6 and then when I
play it in 98 what's the move why do you
want to play five
well where were we were wearing but but
but but how will you force me to take
the bishop no I mean maybe but like no
no no okay okay wait first of all let's
talk about simple tactics 98 what's the
move Bishop takes free porn free game
right the beauty of having space
advantage is okay you win the point you
win the game right it's like you're
gonna win one point and then another and
then another and then you will just push
right that would be the end of the game
okay
so after we sub T six then black had to
take and now I'm gonna play 995 next
move so what can you play with white
with black wherever you play you play
that you lose on the spot right so 98
only moves and now the King will never
be able to go here right okay so then
the question is in this position okay we
have made a lot of progress we have a
lot of disadvantage how will you win we
can try we can try let's look
Kinji for King edge five okay so
typically you would play these two moves
very quickly because why not
but now you need to think carefully
right you need to stop and think does
this work or not so you want to take
right that that's what you said right
now what is your opponent play this
jeez
no draw or maybe you will win now
oh I'm so sad now did I lose
how about if I just take though
yeah that's a draw I'm almost completely
sure that you're losing here yeah
actually I think here and maybe I should
have just no because then you will take
I'll push it and you will promote no no
no no no okay it doesn't matter too much
the point is that you're not winning
anymore no I'm pretty certain I'm pretty
certain so then the question is here
what do you do here
f-five right king takes
so there is a difference of one tempo
and what do you play now
idiot check you need to go check come on
it's like if you can do check you go
check and then hopefully you will take
the other pants with check how would you
play now 26
check check check check
thank you very much we were three points
up they should be a win now I know you
all want to see how this no no but I
think we all want to see how he how he
lost the games so Knight takes pawn take
is at King take and then I said f5 and
then you said g7 right now you said one
take
oh yeah I always get confused with that
poem take yeah Tom take Tom take King
Jesus a king e7 you can't push the pawn
no you can't do you serious I mean you
can but but check I mean it's no I mean
where are you going with this
No okay so overall okay now why did this
crazy move work because we the pawn was
on g6 right because we had space
advantage right and something else that
you will notice about the space
advantage is that throughout the entire
game we were always calling the shots
right we were always the ones that was
kind of deciding what happens and what
doesn't happen creating the threats and
then black always had to defend and
fight the right moves
yeah well I mean there is a reason for
that the reason is that after Pontic you
don't have to yeah I mean like you have
to take their you can play a five and
then here we are sort of stuck right now
you can just play this draw okay so this
is a game by Leon I wonder with white
against hankerin so it was c4 okay
not exactly but but it is a similar bone
structure is a similar middle B what do
you think of this position the d6 pawn
looks weak okay so obviously black had
to defend that in plate f6 okay now I
still have this idea right
so here black play the five and then a6
but okay but so the question was what do
you think about this position like in
other words what's the evaluation of
this position White's better wife that's
the reason right so maybe when you look
at it you have a feeling that white is
better but it's always good to put it in
words because if you can really
understand what's the source of your
advantage then it's much easier for you
to take advantage of it for you to kind
of maintain it and use it right so here
what will you do with white
before with what purpose before to play
b5 let's see let's see so before okay so
I'm gonna try to play against you I'm
not saying it's a bad move but I'll try
to come up with some moves so let's say
that a page five continued a four okay
I'll take King h7 why am I playing this
to attack that that's very big let's be
more specific
okay to play Bishop h6 how about that do
you think Bishop h6 is a good idea yes
or no why yeah because it it diminishes
my space disadvantage and it trades your
most important piece so what I'm doing
kind of makes sense right okay continue
continue a5 okay Bishop a bishop a g6
94 okay now I will trade and then I'll
play not a fix
g4 well he changed his mind that's okay
it's okay to change your mind now I take
check oh my god so annoying
okay let me play we should be five
instead okay but overall I mean they
gave me a little bit confusing right I
mean you had some sort of a nice
advantage and you realize that the
moment that you played this before
immediately played age five and then I
had some contact late one way or the
other
I had some come to play but what if you
have played g4 to understand what Liang
I wonder did he played you for what's
the point
yep
to sort of reduce
yeah and claim some space maybe because
okay one thing that I want you to know
is that if you take on f5 you're not
very likely to create some meaningful
attack on the G file that that's just
unrealistic but if you could pay G 5 and
H for you would you could get some nice
space
that's much more realistic right that's
actually going to happen in this game
now if your opponent pushes for example
to promise for him
number one the bishop is now very
trapped number two
typically people play this copy to push
like this but now that I have already
placed my pawn on d4 how are you going
to accomplish that right so you are kind
of stuck here in a not-so-nice situation
so after you afford the game continue
with Ponte Ponte Bishop f6 how will you
pay with white knight a four to be six
okay let's take a look at that so you
play that then I play here
what be for yeah defy
I'm sorry I always do that have you
noticed how to put the I always tried to
trade on Bishop it always makes me feel
happy
so then what will you do fine I will
trade I'll play here you know what
what's coming up next
like let's say you do nothing I'm gonna
put a rock on a for I'm gonna be pretty
happy with that
makes sense now I will play Bishop d7
next okay and now I'll bring the other
rook okay what is this position
Oh boring right equality maybe right no
more than equality yeah so that's the
problem you're gonna have an advantage
anymore
why just played this shoppi to I guess
b5 don't Brooke the one okay so you want
to create that bishop well nothing I can
do to stop you but in the meantime what
did I do
I activated my group and my bishop you
see now my bishop becomes annoying here
and that's pretty important because when
I put the bishop on c4 I essentially
prevent you from playing me should be
six can you kill Eppley what night under
attack also so take take night of faith
oh isn't that nice
because of this this very direct
tactical threat I prevented you from
achieving a very important long-term
trait
ah no no we're just trying to understand
the position we are not any given color
okay we're just trying to understand the
important ideas in the position
obviously White has the advantage right
yeah so okay so now black is kind of
stuck not being able to do this trade so
what will I do next with wait
age four ooh before why before well
before maybe to stop before that's one
reason to stop Bishop a5 that's another
reason because you're black you need to
get rid of pieces right so that's
another thing and then the other thing
is to kind of stabilize that because h4
can come anytime right age for can wait
before cannot do you see that now your
opponent plays Bishop c8 to the trade no
okay you don't trade now you want to
achieve this break someday your opponent
place there okay so you'll get ready
maybe look c1 okay now your opponent
plays f5 what's your what's your
response a3 why do we play a three
yeah Bishop a5 still stopped what else
the poem b5 is a liability very serious
liability right it's like now that you
have played a five nothing will defend
this pawn or only the row can the bishop
right so now those two beasts are tied
to the defense right so then king of
seven group big one maybe I'm thinking
about taking some day okay so you push
now with white I feel pretty happy why
because now that you have pushed did
these two pawns are in very serious
danger right they might be lost
someday like if I managed to take the
beef upon the a four prong we just
follow automatically okay so how do you
continue okay that would have been worth
it okay so rook f1 let's say up here
what do you continue aged for okay what
else
I will take it I will take it on don't
don't do that
okay well let's see what will happen in
this game it was 91 rogue oh look at the
at page 4 so all of these books are very
non-committal right the only reason I'm
making them is because they kind of
allow me to improve now where do you
think what is going with all of this
like you've liked it nothing for a while
what do you think what would do
94 26
look f1 here
this might be worth it and the point is
that you can't easily trade because you
are kind of looking upon right yeah so
basically the pawn on d6 is lost if you
del to take but if you don't dare to
take then you're kind of losing for
other reasons so you see this neon I
wonder is pretty good so 93 attacking
the pawn rook f1 continue to be annoying
91 okay oh look you want to call him
finally
so you see one of the reasons that black
didn't want to trade this earlier is
that there will always be a weakness on
c7 and then the route could kind of be
annoying there so then King d8 okay Roxy
six obviously defend and then rue k-6
then Rho K five for example if you play
this I'm just going to play rock a5
attacking the pawn and if you wait
anyway they move will lose because of
906 yeah
what a terrible game right what a
terrible game so basically black has
lost from beginning to end and then
after rookie 6 will the game continue
with Knight b6 and r6 then broke then
take and resign because if you take have
a check ok all right so then let's
summarize some of the main ideas of this
position them so I would say that the
position is best defined by this this
moment so in this moment what is it that
we see we have a Kings Indian type 1
position White has a space advantage
there is some possibility to fight for
the foul because we have space advantage
it will be easy for us to claim the file
instead of our opponent so that's one
thing then another thing very important
that's going on here is the fact that
black would like to trade some minor
pieces in order to decrease the space
advantage so with white we make that
difficult right so for example here we
played this g4 claiming more space in
obstructing our opponents play right and
from then on it's just a matter of
having good technique you know being
able to create threat in multiple places
at the same time blocking basic exchange
mechanisms and then making progress
toward the ending ok so let me just
close by giving you one final thought
this is kind of a general recommendation
it would be my general recommendation
that you study
openings seriously and try to figure out
the type of middle game that you will
obtain you can easily classify most
middle games instead of pawn structures
and once you have that then you can
figure out what are the main plans for
each if you're able to do that then when
you play the opening you go in with a
substantial advantage because you not
only you're not only memorizing the the
opening we were actually thinking ahead
of time what plans have the right ones
and then you can sort of remember
similar games that you've seen in the
past in order to make decisions more
effectively for example in this game I
mean I don't think that Liang I wonder
came up with all the ideas like on the
spot obviously when he played g4 he has
seen this before
right he has seen this another game
he knows the type of position is playing
he knows what the preventing will be one
for him right that's why he wins it's
not that he comes up with everything on
the spot right so you need to learn from
other games but you need to know how to
relate games to one another and the best
way to do that is by thinking in terms
of the opening your plane and the poni
structure that you are arriving to ok ok
thank you for coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]